today on the matt wall show joe biden
will start funding organizations that
perform abortions around the world and
he does this
while claiming to be a catholic a devout
catholic no less also five headlines
including
a lawsuit claiming that twitter while
banning conservatives for their
harmful content supposedly failed to
delete accounts that publish child
pornography plus
the white house offers the lamest excuse
possible for biden's failures to
follow his own mask mandates all of that
and much more today
on the matt walsh show
[Music]
[Applause]
you know one of the best win-wins that
we can give ourselves uh
right now especially right now in the
culture is to support
businesses that support us to support
businesses that have the same value
system as us rather than always giving
our money
to businesses that oppose us businesses
that really hate us
even though we're their customers and
that's why charity mobile is such a
great opportunity and such a win-win
opportunity for everybody involved the
pro-life phone company is charity mobile
because
they give five percent of your monthly
plan price right to
the pro-life pro family charity of your
choice it's up to you what chair do you
want to give to
but it's going to be pro life and pro
family a lot of other perks come with
charity mobile including new activations
and eligible accounts which get a
free cell phone with free activation and
free shipping and there's no contract
there's no termination fees there's
no risk with a 30-day guarantee so you
might as well try it out see if you like
the service
uh you got nothing to lose and i think
you will like the service
plus you got live customer service based
right in the usa so everything about
this company is great and all the while
you're helping to build
a culture of life in america while
supporting a pro-life phone company
you can turn everyday living into
effortless giving giving
right to the charity of your choice and
also by the way nationwide service on
america's largest and most reliable
4g lte network i have charity mobile
it's
what's what i've been using for months
now and um i'll tell you another great
thing with my charity mobile service
is that i've i i mean this sincerely
i've never had a call dropout since i
started i've
how long i've been with charity mobile
several months now i've never had a call
drop out on me
i can't guarantee that's gonna be the
case for everybody but that has been my
experience i can tell you that
um you can call them at 1-877-474-3662
or chat with them online at
charitymobile.com
it's expected that at some point today
or in the coming days
joe biden will revoke the mexico city
policy which blocks any tax
dollars from going into the pockets of
organizations around the world that
promote or perform abortions dr fauci
made the announcement while speaking to
the world health organization on
thursday
promising that biden would abolish the
policy and start funding abortions
internationally once again here's
fauci's exact words he says
it'll be our policy to support women's
and girls sexual reproductive health and
reproductive rights in the united states
as well as globally
to that end president biden will be
revoking the mexico city policy
in the coming days as part of his
broader commitment to protect women's
health
and advance gender equality at home and
around the world
now i'm sorry but i can't read a
statement like that without clarifying
and
reiterating that reproductive health is
an incredibly misleading euphemism
for abortion it's really a misnomer
abortion has nothing to do with
reproductive health or reproductive
rights
indeed it has nothing to do with
reproduction at all abortion happens
after reproduction has already occurred
by preventing the birth of the child by
killing it you are not preventing
the reproduction from happening so you
notice when a woman is giving birth
the doctor does not say look she's
reproducing
there are hopefully no doctors in the
vicinity watching during the actual
reproductive act
the birthing act though is when the
already produced child
moves from the mother's womb out into
the great wide world
fauci of course understands this but he
uses these kinds of phrases because he
is a dishonest man
speaking of being dishonest yesterday
the new white house press secretary was
asked about
this and asked whether biden would
reverse this mexico city policy
and she responded with the most
transparent political deflection
in the history of political deflections
we played this clip yesterday during the
headlines
segment but let's uh let's play it again
go ahead all the way in the back
yeah hi uh congratulations on your new
position uh owen jensen with ewtn global
catholic network
two big concerns for pro-life americans
the hyde amendment
which of course uh keeps
tax payer dollars as you know from
paying for abortions medicaid abortions
and the mexico city policy which under
the previous administration
expanded to keep tax dollars from
overseas paying for abortions
so what are president what is president
biden planning on doing in those two
items right now uh
well i think we'll have more to say on
the mexico city policy in the coming
days
um but i will just take the opportunity
to
remind all of you that he is a devout
catholic and somebody who
attends church regularly he started his
day attending church with his family
this morning
but i don't have anything more don't
have anything more
for that all i have is this irrelevant
note that's all i got
as i also explained yesterday no joe
biden is not a devout catholic he's not
any kind of catholic he's not even a bad
catholic he's a
catholic he's a catholic only in the
same sense that i'm a humpback whale
which is to say i'm not a humpback well
words have meaning
as much as the left might wish it were
otherwise the word catholic
has meaning part of what it means to be
a catholic is to accept an ascent to the
moral authority of the church
if you don't believe the church has more
authority then there's no reason to be
catholic
and there is no sense in which you are a
catholic
if you think that the church and its
official teachings
gets it wrong sometimes and right
sometimes
then you have the exact attitude towards
the church
that every non-catholic has because you
are a non-catholic
no matter what else you say so i can say
that there are probably some things
from my perspective that jehovah's
witnesses believe that i also believe
there are some things that maybe they
get right not many things in my opinion
but some they don't celebrate birthdays
for example and i also don't like
birthdays so i think they're on the
right path with that one
but i can also say that i don't accept
the fundamental teachings of the
jehovah's witness church if i did accept
it
then i'd be a jehovah's witness the very
thing that makes me
not a jehovah's witness is that i don't
accept it
and this is the very thing that makes
joe biden not a catholic
and by the way this is something i would
be saying even if i myself was not a
catholic
nothing i'm saying here has anything to
do with my being a catholic this is
merely about the definitions of things
and i know by definition you cannot in
any meaningful sense
be a member of a religion much less a
devout member
if you don't share the core beliefs of
that religion on that score
i think this is important to note what
does the church say about the subject of
abortion
well there's a lot to say actually
through through the centuries
let's check the catechism always a good
thing to consult for these questions and
i quote
that's what the catholic church says
human life must be respected and
remember this is what the religion that
joe biden claims
devout adherence to says
human life must be respected and
protected absolutely from the moment of
conception
from the first moment of his existence a
human being must be recognized as having
the rights of a person
among which is the invaluable right of
every innocent being
to life since the first century the
church has affirmed the moral evil of
every procured abortion this teaching
has not changed and remains unchangeable
direct abortion that is to say an
abortion willed either as an ends or a
means
is gravely contrary to the moral law
formal cooperation in an abortion
constitutes a grave offense
the church attaches the canonical
penalty of excommunication to this crime
against human life
a person who procures a completed
abortion incurs excommunication by the
very commission of the offense
and subject to the conditions provided
by canon law the church does not thereby
intend to restrict the scope of mercy
rather she makes the clear
she makes clear the gravity of the crime
committed the irreparable harm done to
the innocent who is put to death
as well as to the parents of the whole
of society the inalienable right to life
of every innocent human individual
is a constitutive element of a civil
society and its legislation
okay i'm biased but i think that's
pretty good
that's good stuff this is the moral
teaching of the church
you are absolutely free to disregard it
laugh in its face
say that's a bunch of malarkey come on
man you're free to do that
you're not free to do that while still
claiming to be a catholic just as i
am not free to get married while still
remaining a bachelor
have to choose one or the other this is
not a matter of
legal compulsion but of logical
conclusion
you cannot be in a religion that you
fundamentally reject
and you cannot support the legalization
and funding of abortion
here and across the globe while also
accepting the truth of everything i just
read from the catechism
choices must be made joe biden has made
his choice he has long since made it
and his choice puts him outside far
outside the religion he claims
membership in and devotion to
does that mean that joe biden has no
religion no it doesn't mean that
this is the other important thing to
understand he in fact
belongs to the largest and fastest
growing religion in the west
that being the religion of self that is
joe biden's religion
and the great thing about being in the
religion of self where you worship and
idolize your own ambitions and desires
is that you don't have to do the work of
building the religion from scratch
you can dip into other established
religions borrow the bits you prefer the
bits you like
joe biden likes going to church which is
nice good for him so that that becomes
part of his religious practice
not his catholic religious practice
because he isn't a catholic but part of
his devotion to self
he does it because he likes it so it's
about him
he doesn't like the stuff about abortion
he doesn't like the stuff about marriage
and family he doesn't like the stuff
about
man and woman he created them doesn't
like that either doesn't like any of
that so he discards it
keeps only the parts he likes gets rid
of everything else
the one overriding theme the lit the
litmus test which determines which
doctrines will be adhered to and which
will be tossed aside
is how those doctrines serve him
and make him feel and how convenient
they are
for him seems like kind of a sweet deal
you know members of traditional
religions may look at these
self-worshipers self-idolizers and think
man
must be nice to put together your own
version i mean you know there's there's
some stuff i wish i could toss aside be
a lot easier make my life a lot easier
get rid of the heart hard parts assemble
your own religion like you're playing
with a box of legos
seems nice but rest assured that the
religion of self is not so fun as it
looks it is at its core
as empty as the people who belong to it
it leads only to more emptiness
and ultimately despair and failure
except for a very very select few
who may ride it all the way to the white
house enjoying for a fleeting moment
the power they've been grasping for
their entire lives
which honestly in the end still seems
pretty empty to me
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
all right you know i i gotta say i can't
i hate to keep complaining about the
food in the break room here at um
daily wire because the truth is actually
there's a lot of great food
and i'm surprised by how much they feed
us here i wasn't expecting that
just constantly giving us food and all i
do is eat all day
really i've gained like 70 pounds since
i started working in the office but
i i was walking through this morning and
i saw a tray out
of um it was a little bags
and it was premium roasted
seaweed like in the form of almost a
granola bar
premium roasted seaweed i don't know who
i don't know who the maniac is here
who eats that stuff i want to report
them to hr
and this is this is one of those things
i see that reminds me sometimes that um
many of the people that i work with
are from la you know that's because
that's where the company came from
um and so that's i see stuff like that
and i'm like okay yeah this must be an
la thing
or i open the i open the fridge and it's
nothing but fake milk
oat milk coconut milk almond milk none
of that none of that is real milk by the
way in any sense whatsoever
reminds me of that on the other hand i'm
you know i i moved here from
rural pennsylvania and i lived in a town
quite literally a one
stop sign we didn't have a stop light we
had a stop sign it wasn't even a
four-way stop it was a three-way stop we
had one stop sign
we had a post office a bar and we
we had a gas station convenience store
that's all we had and i just think if i
were to have walked into that gas
station convenience store in rural
pennsylvania
and asked if they had premium roasted
seaweed
they might have pulled a gun on me get
out of here
we don't we don't take kindly to you
seaweed chompers around here
maybe that's what they would have said i
don't know um all right let's get to
number one from the
the new york post this is if you're
looking to be
totally horrified well then you come to
the right place here it is
twitter refused to take down widely
shared pornographic images and videos of
a teenage sex
trafficking victim because an
investigation
didn't find a violation of the company's
policies this is all according to a
lawsuit
the federal suit filed wednesday by the
victim and his mother in the northern
district of california alleges twitter
made money off the clips
which showed a 13 year old engaged in
sex acts and
are a form of child sexual abuse
material or child porn the suit states
the teen who's now 17 and lives in
florida
is identified only as john doan was
between 13 and 14 years old when sex
traffickers posing as a 16 year old
female classmate
started chatting with him on snapchat
according to the suit this is all
according to
the lawsuit so i wanted to keep saying
that um doe when the traffickers
allegedly
exchanged nude photos before the
conversation turned to blackmail if the
teen didn't share more
sexually graphic photos and videos the
explicit material he'd already sent
would be shared with his parents coach
pastor and others
do acting under duress initially
complied and sent videos of himself
performing sex acts and was also
told to include another child in his
videos which he did
eventually doe blocked the traffickers
they stopped harassing him but at some
point in 2019 the video surfaced on
twitter under two accounts
that were known to share child sexual
abuse material
over the next month the videos will be
reported to twitter at least three times
but the tech giant failed to do anything
about it
until a federal law enforcement agent uh
got involved
and i'm not gonna keep reading this
entire thing it's a long report worth
reading though but
to uh to summarize finally so this is
child porn being put
on um as a sex trafficking victim
which by the way you know you almost
don't need to save both of those because
if it's child porn this is a sex
trafficking victim
by definition this is a person who's
being abused by definition
and so this stuff is on twitter
and it's allowed to be there and
according to the lawsuit
they report it multiple times
and we're originally told that it
doesn't violate the terms of service
until finally federal agents got
involved and then they took it down
so you just you keep that in mind
when you hear about twitter uh taking
down
kicking donald trump off the platform
because of his harmful abusive material
inciting and all that kind of stuff all
these conservatives were kicked off
the new york post was shut down for
months
because of its harmful material
misleading material
yet this is allowed to remain
and part of that is now part of it is
obviously ideological and it's the it's
the
bias against conservatives and all that
stuff so we know about that but
uh the other part of it is is that there
are just a lot of
people many of them running these big
tech giants
who don't see abusive pornography as
obscene
because these are talk about empty
amoral soulless people well
that's who they are so when they think
about harmful material online
what they mean and what and what comes
to mind for them
are ideas that they don't agree with
and they don't want other people to be
exposed to so for them that that is what
obscenity is
it's an idea they don't like
but child pornography any kind of
pornography no that's that's not obscene
that's what free speech i guess they
would tell us
number two joe biden was asked about his
vaccine
rollout plan and here's how that
i think we're gonna get a lot of
exchanges like this but here's how that
exchange went
[Music]
where the u.s is right now when i
announced that you all said it's not
possible come on give me a break man
that's the question good start 100
million
so he was asked about this plan to give
100 million vaccines and the report was
well maybe we should be getting more
than that is that enough
and joe biden's answer is come on man
give me a break and then he just gets up
and leaves
that's why that's the answer
um meanwhile the media has
consistently claimed that biden is
starting from scratch he's
talking about the the vaccine rollout
plan well the claim we've heard from
from the media many times over the last
couple days and this exact phrase
they're starting from scratch because
trump hadn't done anything
even though he had operation warp drive
and they were
it certainly seemed like there's plenty
being done but the media said no no
nothing was done starting from scratch
he's got to do it all himself
well dr fauci was asked about this at a
press conference and here's what he said
just ask you about the effort to
distribute the vaccines because of
course
that's what makes people want to know
when are they going to get a vaccine
is the biden administration starting
from scratch
with the vaccine distribution effort or
are you picking up where the trump
administration left off
no i mean um we certainly are not
starting from scratch because there is
activity going on in the distribution
but if you look at the plan
that the president has put forth about
the things that he is going to do
namely get community vaccine centers up
get pharmacies more involved
where appropriate get the defense
production act involved
not only perhaps with getting more
vaccine but even the things you need
to get a good vaccine program for
example
needles and syringes that might be more
useful than that
yeah by the way it's operation warp
speed i'm informed not warp drive
warp drive that's that's some that's
that's a little different that's star
trek i think
so you get a little confused anyway um
so not starting not starting from
scratch there there was obviously
already something in place
but so fauci said that but he also said
something else which is uh he was he was
on cnn i think a little bit later that
day
it was earlier today same day um when he
agreed that
the uh according to him the the
supposedly the dishonesty from the trump
administration led to people
dying uh let's let's listen to that clip
so the white house released its new
coronavirus strategy yesterday and they
came out with this 21-page
summary of it and the number one thing
the number one goal
of the new buying wise house in terms of
battling the pandemic
is to restore trust with the american
people
why is it necessary to say that
well i think that that was really good
making that number one because what
we've had
john there's no secret we've had a lot
of divisiveness we've had
facts that were very very clear that
were questioned
people were not trusting what health
officials were saying there was great
divisiveness
masking became a political issue so what
the president was saying right from the
get-go
you know let's reset this let's
everybody get on the on the on the same
page
trust each other let the science speak
and he said that multiple times
did the lack of candor did the lack of
facts
in some cases over the last year cost
lives
you know it very likely did you know i
don't want that john to be a sound bite
but i think if you just look at that you
could see
that when you're starting to go down
paths that are not based on any science
at all and we've been there before i
don't want to
rehash it that is not helpful at all
i don't want it to be a sound bite but
uh here's a sound i don't want to give
you a sound bite but here's one
of course that's a sound bite he damn
well knows it
we want to talk about lack of candor uh
what about from fauci himself
who who was among the people early on
saying you don't need to wear a mask all
of our
sacred public health experts and
officials
not just um not just donald trump
early on saying you don't need masks
and now they say uh if you don't wear a
mask you know you're killing people
now i i my personal opinion is that they
were
more right the first time but according
to what they're saying now
if you believe what they're saying now
then that means
that people like fauci and any other
public health experts that don't wear a
mask early on
they're responsible for killing people
according to what they're saying now
but of course there's there's no
accountability for that whatsoever
moving on number three um speaking of a
lack of accountability
so we played the clip for yesterday joe
biden uh you know he passes this exe
not even passes is not the word he
enacts an executive order
requiring that masks be worn uh during
interstate travel and if you're on in
federal property you gotta wear a mask
uh well then right right after signing
that executive order he goes
and he's on federal properties at the
lincoln memorial and he's not wearing a
mask
and at the white house press conference
that question was brought up and here's
how that was handled
go ahead why weren't president biden
and all members of the biden family
masked at all times on federal lands
last night if he
signed an executive order that mandates
masks on federal
lands at all times at the inaugural
memorial yes i i think he was
celebrating an evening of a historic day
in our country and certainly he signed
the mask mandate because
it's a way to send a message to the
american public about
the importance of uh wearing masks how
it can save
tens of thousands of lives we take a
number of coveted precautions as you
know here in terms of
testing social distancing mass squaring
ourselves as
as we do every single day but i don't
know that i have more for you on it than
that
oh so because they were celebrating
that's why you didn't wear a mask
they're just celebrating
and you know just making a joke here
here's the thing
the answer is well the real answer is we
have we have different rules for us
and you peons have to do things
differently than we do you know we're
more important than you and we can do
what we want also
we don't really believe most of stuff
we're telling you and so that's why
we we carry on and we're around other
people not wearing a mask
you know we we as people in power we we
really haven't changed our lifestyle
at all except when the cameras are on
because we don't believe a lot of what
we're telling you that's the real answer
but there is a version of the answer
that's
reasonable if you want to say well look
it's a judgment call he's
he's you know this he's at this
celebration there's not there's not a
bunch of people right on top of him
he's trying to speak he wants to be
understood
so he took the mask off and
that part that i would be fine with
if everybody else was given that same
grace the problem is they're not
because this is the point that many
people in america have made
i think a lot of people in america if i
were to summarize their position on mass
i don't want to speak for everybody but
i think there's probably a lot of people
i've spoken to anyway
who their position on mask is basically
like i understand in certain situations
i wear the mask but in other situations
it seems unreasonable to wear it and it
it's it's especially if i'm i'm you know
i'm trying to be
if i want to be understood i'm trying to
speak to somebody and they're not right
on top of me
maybe take the mask off i think that's a
lot of that's the position a lot of
people have
if i'm in my own home i'm having a
celebration i want to have everyone
wearing masks
that's the position a lot of people have
perfectly reasonable the problem is that
the powers that be
they allow themselves that grace and and
for them they can make those judgment
calls
but they don't trust us to make those
judgment calls
that's what it comes down to they just
simply don't trust you
or me to make judgment calls
that's what it was on early on with the
masks and they admitted that that's why
they first said
oh don't wear the masks masks and and
and they
later told us the reason was well we
don't want all you morons to run out and
hoard all the masks and then there
wouldn't be any left for healthcare
workers
i'm slightly i'm only slightly
paraphrasing
the official reason given okay so
you lied um
because you were trying to manipulate us
because you don't trust our judgment
because we think we're a bunch of idiots
and that's how you're governing and it
seems that that is uh
continuing here continuing that vein
number four from ign it says microsoft
has
filed a patent that would allow the
company to digitally revive
deceased loved ones as chat bots
using the individual's personal
information the independent reports that
the tech giant has raised the
possibility of creating an
ai based chat bot that would be built
upon the profile of a person which
includes their images
voice data social media posts electronic
messages among other types of personal
information
it's understood that the chatbot would
then be able to to simulate human
conversation through voice commands and
or text chats
however microsoft has take microsoft has
taken the concept a step further
by suggesting that a 2d or 3d model of a
specific person
could potentially be created using
images and depth depth information
depth of information or video data of an
individual in order to
build a chatbot that has the same
characteristics and behavior
based on the digital output of a
specific person
oh this is good thing is this is not
creepy at all
it isn't creepy or weird at all this to
me is this is no different
really than putting your loved ones
ashes into an urn
and then drawing a face on it like like
it's tom hanks's volleyball
in castaway and setting it down to the
dinner table and having a full-on
conversation with it
it's really no different because it's
just your imagination anyway the
person's not really there
you're speaking to a chatbot it's not
really that person
can we can we not this is all i'm asking
modern society
you know i've tolerated a lot can we not
with this
can this be one thing we just don't do
can we draw a line here at least
resurrecting our dead loved ones and
turning them into
chat bots i i i we gotta draw a line we
gotta draw it somewhere don't we
uh number five finally the account
called
design boom on twitter has pictures of a
proposed
proposed tower in new york city and the
caption reads
uh harry attack proposes the striking
sinuous
sarco style tower for the new york
skyline
and there are pictures of it uh and if
you're
you could go and see these pictures i
have never
i've truly never seen a building you
really you really have to look at this
building
they're proposed they really want to put
this building in new york in the skyline
i have never seen a building
that so seamlessly manages to be
disturbing hideous and hilarious all at
once
it's kind of funny but it's also ugly as
hell
and terrifying it looks like a bounce
house in hell
it's like something satan would have at
his kid's birthday party
that's what i imagine or maybe it's a it
looks a little bit like a building
that dr seuss might design if he was
tripping on acid
it really does look like something from
a different dimension and not in a good
way
but in another sense it's unremarkable
because it's it's just
more modern architecture that is ugly
and aggressive
and bad and depressing so here's another
line that i hope we draw let's not do
that either
okay um before we get to our daily
cancellation i do have to i almost
forgot to play this i cannot forget to
play this
the best clip of the day of indeed the
year the year is young but
this certainly i think is is the best so
far
chuck schumer on the floor of the senate
no introduction required here's what he
said make no mistake
there will be a trial and when that
trial ends senators will have to decide
if they believe donald john donald john
trump
incited the erection insurrection
against the united states
incited the erection
an erection against the united states
that's you don't want that
as a country you don't want to be facing
that
certainly uh at least like i mean now we
we know
why chuck schumer has been so obsessed
with donald trump for the last four
years he couldn't do anything but talk
about donald trump
um he has been upset at donald trump for
inciting his erections
all this time
that's it's we're starting to understand
the psychology a little bit behind chuck
schumer
understanding it more than i ever wanted
to to be honest with you one thing about
being an adult
and owning a house is that you know you
need to you need to class things up a
little bit and that's when you need real
artwork on your walls that's how you
separate the adults from the
from the from the posers do you have
artwork on the wall
and if you're looking to to do that in
your home you got to try painting your
life in fact we're in the process of
buying a house right now
and we're gonna be going back to paint
your life we already got a few paintings
from them
we're gonna be going back again because
paint your life is is just great you can
get a professional hand-painted portrait
created from any photo at a truly
affordable price
you can choose from a team of
world-class artists and work with them
until
every detail is absolutely perfect it's
a user-friendly platform lets you order
a custom-made hand-painted portrait in
less than five minutes
on your end it's a it's a really short
really short very very quick easy
process
um it's also it's also hands-on you can
be as hands-on as you want to be i was
impressed
uh by that with my experience where
they're asking you throughout while
they're painting it you know do you have
any specifications any notes anything
you want to change they're always
willing to do that
it's a quick and easy process you get a
hand-painted portrait in about three
weeks it'll be sent right to you
makes the perfect birthday gift
anniversary gift a wedding gift
you know you're going to be the hit of
the party at a birthday party if you
give someone a gift like that or
get a give a gift to yourself and get
paint your life at paintyourlife.com
there's no risk
if you don't love the final painting
your money is refunded
guaranteed and right now as a limited
time offer get 20
off your painting that's right 20 off
and free shipping to get this special
offer text the word matt to sixty four
thousand that's matt to sixty four
thousand text matt m att
the sixty four thousand paint your life
celebrate the moments that matter most
terms apply available at paint your life
dot com slash terms again text matt
to 64 000. and
um while you're online make sure you go
to dailywire.com
become a member today and you can use
promo code rhf to get 25
off rhf of course stands for run height
fight that's uh our new movie we're very
excited about
everyone's excited about everyone's
excited about it except maybe some of
the mainstream media critics who um
you know have been less than friendly
although our tomato meter score over rod
tomatoes
has gone up a little bit for the critics
we're now up to 30 that's exciting
what's more exciting is that the
audience score is 93
here's what one of the critics has to
say at variety guy lodge he says
what would you do the film tastelessly
needles its viewers throughout
presenting the brawniest most impossible
answer all the while
so he don't like it because it's brawny
meanwhile here's a review from
just a normal audience member they call
it brilliant they say they say the
the suspense of watching your worst
fears as a student come to life on your
screen and watch it be conquered gives
everyone a sense of personal hope and
power exactly what we need during the
pandemic
that's what that's the kind of stuff
we've been hearing from the audience
we're excited to bring you great stories
that hollywood refuses to tell
and we can do that now at twenty five
percent off if use promo code rhf so go
watch the movie
and if you like it don't forget to leave
a review let's get now to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
today for our daily cancellation we're
going to be canceling some of the people
some of you in the audience i'm afraid
who have sent messages emails left
comments
in response to the show over the last
couple of days i as i have been arguing
that the best thing conservatives can do
to win back the culture is to localize
their focus and set out to make the sort
of profound
and meaningful changes in their own
lives and communities that they have the
power to make there's a lot
there's a lot going on in washington
that we cannot do anything about
um even if we try there's a lot going on
in our families in our communities
that we could do something about but we
don't try
as i said as many have said the
condition of the family determines the
condition of the culture so to simplify
my plan it can be put like this
in the simplest form have a bunch of
kids
and homeschool them to expand it a
little bit i suggest that we buy land
buy guns buy books turn the tv off
uh that's that's the way to live i can't
take credit for this plan it was
actually already proposed by the singer
john prine
may he rest in peace in his song spanish
pipe dream which is a great song
if you've never heard it in his words he
says blow up your tv throw away your
paper go to the country build you a home
plant a little garden eat a lot of
peaches try and find jesus on your own
this indeed is the way take or leave the
peaches but the rest of it yes is the
best path
forward but i have heard from a number
of people well-meaning fine people i'm
sure
though they're still all canceled who
take issue with this plan they say that
this is surrender it is a waving of the
white flag to pull your kids out of the
school system to get them away from the
cities to extract them
even a little bit from the from the pull
of of of social media and pop culture
we can't do this they say we need to we
need to remain immersed in these
environments our kids have to remain
immersed
so that we can really fight and achieve
ultimate victory
the common refrain i've heard many many
times over the years when i've advocated
for homeschooling
is that conservative parents should send
their kids to public schools so that the
kids can be a light
to others a light in the darkness and
also so that they can be equipped to
live in our society and withstand the uh
trials and temptations that come with it
etc
now i think this attitude is completely
wrong and i'll explain why
it comes down to this children
do not learn to stand apart from the
culture
or to be individuals by being totally
immersed
in it from the moment of birth they
especially don't learn this they don't
learn how to be lights how to be
warriors for truth as we want them to be
by attending public school all through
their formative years i know it doesn't
work that way
because i have eyes and i can look
around and i can see that it doesn't
work that way
and hasn't worked that way on the
contrary
total immersion in the culture
especially with respect to public school
has the effect of conditioning our
children
most kids don't learn to be brave and
bold and savvy by spending all their
time in this environment instead
they learn to be just like everyone else
there are exceptions to this rule and
you could say oh my kids are the
exception
maybe they are they probably aren't you
probably think they are but they
actually aren't
but maybe they are the thing is though
that exceptions are just that they're
exceptions the general rule is that
public school produces the kinds of kids
that the system is designed to produce
and part of that design
in public school is that the primary
influence over your child
the people who'll be most prominently
teaching your child and setting the
example are not the teachers
but his peers this is who he's going to
spend most of his time with
it is their approval that he will most
seek
kids in fact he will learn to live for
their approval
that's what kids today learn they learn
to live
they are desperate for the approval of
their peers
so desperate in fact that if they don't
get it
or if they get it and then the approval
is taken away
so many kids will kill themselves
this this is something that was unheard
of to have 12 year old kids
committing suicide unheard of
for much of american history
now it happens and it's almost like we
take it for granted instead of asking
how the hell is this happening why is it
happening
well it's because kids in school are
conditioned by each other
to act like each other
to want to be each other this is a
problem because none of them have any
clue about anything
they're all running in circles following
each other the blind leading the blind
leading the blind leading the blind
leading the blind
so if our goal is to raise our kids to
fight the good fight then we have to
first train and equip them before we
send them out into the battlefield
conservative parents today many of them
at least send their children out before
they've been fully equipped and trained
and expect it all to sort of magically
turn out okay it probably won't
it doesn't in most cases this is why
it's necessary to put some distance
between the culture and our kids to give
them space to learn and grow and be kids
because they're you know before they're
subjected to the constant oppressive
unrelenting pressure to conform it isn't
fair to subject them to that pressure
before they've been given the tools to
handle it
it's like sending your kid into the
woods with a saw and four nails
and telling him to build a house for
himself maybe the smartest and most
naturally resourceful kids will figure
it out and they'll somehow build a house
but most will not a whole lot of kids
are going to fail
who would not have failed had they been
given a few more tools and maybe a bit
of instruction
before being sent into the wilderness
and no kids do not learn anything
anything good or constructive anyway
from
failing at tasks for which there was any
re for which there was there was there
was never any real chance of success in
the first place
in other words we don't teach our kids
good lessons
by setting them up for failure
now you you set your kid up for success
and he has all the tools and he has all
the instruction he needs and and you
send him out and
he fails in that case well then yeah
there are lessons to be learned from
that
right but when he set up from failure to
be get with for failure to begin with
and he's never given the tools for
success and then he fails
what's the lesson if anything that's a
lesson that we should be learning as
parents
but we don't something else to keep in
mind if you're if you're worried that
your kid
you know might need to go to public
school so that they're prepared for the
real world
you know remember that nothing in the
real world
outside of public school is anything
like public school
it is a unique environment that your
child will never experience
again i can tell you that living my
adult life i have never encountered a
situation
ever anywhere that caused me to go oh
geez i'm glad public school prepared me
for this
in public school a child is in a
building well usually in a building not
with standing coveted shutdowns
he's in a building segregated by age
shuffled from one room to the next where
he sits and listens to an authority
figure tell him things before going to
the next room
and repeating that and then finally
going home i am not aware of
any workplace that functions that way or
any other place anywhere that functions
that way
your child's experience in public school
if it prepares him for anything
it prepares him to be in public school
and that's it
maybe this is why despite how it's
portrayed public school kids are so
poorly socialized so ill-equipped for
adult life
because they've spent all of their time
in an environment that so lacks any
resemblance to the real world
now you could say the same is true of
homeschooling you know where are you
going to go in life that's like
homeschooling
of course it's not exactly like the real
world that's the point we don't have our
kids all the way in the quote real world
yet because they're kids
but it does more resemble what they'll
see in the real world when they're in
homeschooling
they're you know they're around other
people that aren't only their own age
they're with their family you know one
thing it'll prepare them for
is to have a family that's part of being
in the real world
they're gonna be around their parents so
much that it'll better prepare them to
be
parents in the long run to be adults
because they're around and they're
getting this one-on-one attention from
an adult
so much of it in fact when you hear
about
homeschool kids and how they're weird
and all these you know oh the homeschool
kids are so weird
you know i don't think they're weird at
all but if they are weird
it's only because they're so mature in
comparison to their peers
so if there's any trouble them fitting
in it's because they're they are more
like adults than they are like
their peers but that's a good thing
that's a good problem to have
to have your kid be mature in the right
way
uh at a young age
so that's
what you get from public school and
that's why i propose again
pull the kids out give them a little bit
of space i'm not saying put them in the
bubble
although honestly if i had a bubble to
put my kids then i'd probably put them
in that too
given the way the world is going you
don't need to go to that extent though
pull them out put a little bit of buffer
a little bit of space between your kids
in the world
give them space to grow space to breathe
space to figure out who they are
space to learn from you without a
million other voices competing and
tearing them away from you
that's the way to go and so all the
people
sending me comments emails i appreciate
your input but unfortunately you are
canceled and that's gonna do it for us
today and for the week have a great
weekend everybody
have a great um i'll talk to you next
week godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin
stevens production manager pavel
ledovsky the show is edited by danny
d'amico
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matte wall show is a
daily wire production
copyright dailywire2021 technocrats
rejoice
and run amok biden forces little girls
to undress in the same room as men
and a republican congressman prepares
articles of impeachment against
president biden
on his first full day in office check it
out on the michael knowles show